joining us right here the host of
College GameDay
on ESPN and a longtime friend and a man
who is a gas that I have a blind spot in
my movie-watching victory history of
Roadhouse and Point Break I've never
even seen it period it's a Rhys Davis
how are you Rhys
I'm doing great Rick how are you I'm
doing are you embarrassed to know me now
Maurice are you embarrassed to know me
no no not at all actually because as I
texted you while I was watching your
show and came across this little piece
of knowledge that surprised me
yes Roadhouse is a is an awful movie but
it's so awful that it's awesome exam I
and I watch it every time I stumble
across it or at least watch a good
portion of it and much to my wife's
chagrin I met but wait there they're
about to tell us the double deuce right
now see you got Brockman laughing right
now Sam Elliott's flow in that movie my
god
so your wife your wife quick quick so we
have a and this is going to be a
highlight of this person's career that
I'm about to mention his name on
criticises show okay but we have we have
a producer named Jonathan Lubavitch and
I remember the name I remember I
remember remember Lobo it's just so mark
May and I did a game and we for some
reason our announcement Lou I think was
with us too we went in and we joined
LeBeau [ __ ] crew for for a game I
don't know why why that happened but it
did and we're in the production meeting
and all of the people you know all of
the the production assistants and tape
runners whenever the bhavish would ask
him a question they would go and maybe
if they didn't have something done yet
they go I'm sorry boss I'm sorry boss
and I was like Bobo why did what is up
with this I'm sorry boss because oh we
all love Roadhouse it's like a big
inside joke so they treated him like he
was the villain in at Brad Wesley and
every time he asked for something they'd
go I'm sorry boss and I found that
hilarious in there yeah
so do you want to institute that here
Chris because we could start doing that
no because you've never seen the damn
movie like the point
well it's I've never seen it from
complete start to finish I've only seen
certain scenes of it I mean I'm not
completely in the dark we did have Kelly
Lynch here on this show about three four
years ago and did you post that video I
did
okay I did I was about to say Reese if
he said no he would have to say I'm
sorry boss peak Lynch at that point very
good you know it's kind of funny Reese
you want to talk about old school here
and that's another reason why I want to
go down this wormhole with you here was
the last dance and and how many people
just got so much of a kick out of seeing
the old school sports centers from back
in the day and it caused me to think
that you know I was just telling the
guys here that the first guy did
multiple sports centers in a week with
was we was he it was you they teamed us
up quite a bit in my first year that I
was there and it was a total blast it
was an absolute total blast back in 1986
I wondering what you felt watching all
these old school sports center
highlights show up over the last several
weeks I mean it's sort of remarkable I
think rich how much time has passed but
I also think it's pretty remarkable at
the draw that you feel to it and I don't
think it's just because you and I were
fortunate enough to be part of it I
think it was such a part of the way that
dynasty particularly was shared with
sports fans that it became a little tiny
part of it I mean it's not as important
as you know all of the things it
actually happened with the Bulls but
there were people outside of Chicago
that that was the way that they
connected with them throughout the
season and to be able to you know to be
able to see all of us back in our much
younger days and that were at least part
of chronicling that iconic run and and
maybe the greatest dynasty and in modern
NBA I understand Celtics one more and
all that but during that time to have
the transcendent star and the
transcendent team and to be part of
chronicling down
what was the ultimate place to get
highlights and information at the time
as you know it's a kick to be able to
see it and watch it and to watch it
replay in your head and remember things
about it like I was I was the host of
the NBA on ESPN Radio for the finals in
in 97 I was doing MBA two night by then
yes the - I love it and when Buckner and
I yeah were the pregame over the pregame
host and you know brent and dr. jack
called the game on ESPN radio and the
flu game or the poisoned pizza game or
the bad pizza game was too many cigars
game or whatever it was it made Michael
sick we were in our our pregame show and
Quinn had some because this friendship
with Michael had some access back there
and off the air who's that Reese I don't
think he's going to be able to go and
I'm like dare you you're crazy there's
no way it won't play and he goes you eat
you don't see him right now like I'm not
sure the man can lift his head off the
table and it was it was it was something
to be at least a small part of and
certainly brings back a lot of great
memories were you there were you
stationed in Bristol no no I was there
we were we were in Salt Lake City for it
and you know the Jazz really the Jazz
probably should have been up in that
series three games to one because they
sort of blew game one in Chicago and
they'd won the first two in Salt Lake
City and you know that's it's part of
the lore of Michael's performance I
think was that that that series easily
could have been lost and perhaps should
have been on the brink of being lost
even even before that game yeah I mean
that would I mean dr. Jack Ramsey was
one of the greatest human beings I have
ever ever come across and I mean to be
in the middle of all that Reese that
that's real I did not know that or
recall that that that was your
assignment back in the day I was fort
holding you know back in Bristol but you
were out there you were with the guys
and in the middle of the night yeah it
was uh it was really really remarkable
thing it was I I just a few days ago
wrote a foreword for a colleagues book
and
that was about the time they moved me to
the car racing show and I mentioned in
there that I had a gig that I was really
enjoying because I you know I loved
football basketball obviously and to be
part of the NBA and be at that for that
assignment coming off that assignment of
Dan was out there covering it for Sports
Center and you know and having Brent be
you know they play-by-play down radio to
spending a lot of time with him for the
first time in my career it was well it
was one of those one of those epiphany
moments that you have and realizing that
this is a really cool opportunity you've
been blessed with us when we were headed
back to Chicago for Game six Brent and I
were sharing a cab sort of you know we
chatted although remember to sort of
sitting there in silence you're looking
at it out at the Wasatch Mountains and I
sort of turn the other way and I'm like
wait a minute I'm in the backseat of a
cab you're kind of going through doing
your job and not allowing yourself to be
affected like that that uh that in that
moment was was pretty cool who paid for
it and expensed a tree sewer your breath
do you know why did for sure figured I'd
ask okay so the car show that you did
was was at rpm tonight was that p.m. -
yeah - night again and when they called
and asked me to move rich I told them I
said look if you guys think hey let's
get the southern guide or do the car
racing show us just that the wrong dude
well here's what I'll learn it and so
that's what I had to learn it I
certainly didn't know it we're all here
let's go down a little bit memory lane
here a little bit more with rece Davis
who I've known good Lord for about 24
years now right here on the Rich Eisen
show
I never hosted NBA tonight I did I did I
never hosted NHL tonight that was Bill
PTO's territory but I did do arm one of
my first assignments when I was there I
think it was you might want to look this
up Chris I think you look like you're
already looking something else up right
now but you might want to look this up I
think I did the intermission I hosted
the intermission segments for a for
overtime playoff hockey
between the Penguins and buyers could
have been the Flyers penguins it was at
the time the third-longest hockey game
in the history of hockey the two other
ones were from the thirties well before
there was television let alone cable
television intermission sponsored
intermission segments III held a record
at that point in time so that was my
only NHL and I but I went up to NHL two
night where Peeta went on the air I
think at 2:45 in the morning is this in
2000 no this was in 1996 okay as
Penguins played a 5ot in 2000 and here's
another one Reese I did I hosted one
single rpm tonight the one I think cuz
Kenny main got sick or something like
that yeah and so I think I went on the
air and started by saying Omni only
hosted rpm tonight history who has to
call triple-a to change a tire I did not
recall that I'm the only host in or p.m.
tonight history who's got to call
triple-a to change a tire I got no idea
2496
Penguins kappa yo peter Nedved in the
4th over god bless him he sent me home
and built a dome on the air and I was I
I got there in February of 96 so that's
what I was doing is probably a few
sports centers with you and then that's
it those are many oh those are my only
two night historic historic moments
Reese back in the day yeah it was it was
quiet it was quite a training ground I
did a few of those intermissions as well
and you know you were you were kind of
out there without much of a safety net
but it was it was fun man I mean you
don't know those are the things you end
up talking about more than anything else
is those those nights for the night that
a Jim Everett and Jim Rome got in a
fight you know on that Chrissy one more
time and all that stuff was it for that
Reese because I wouldn't know I don't I
don't think I was there I think I I
think I was on the old sport smash the
night after so it was still it was still
buzzing I don't know if Kenny had duty
that night or who it was but that was
that was my first assignment was the the
sports smash updates at the
in the bottom of the hour on the old
espn2 grunge graphic look well you know
you you could have Reese done those
State Farm you know deep fakes as
yourself you're like I think the only
one that could have done it today
without any deep fake because you look
exactly the same as you did back in 1997
and 98 you're the only one I think Reese
you know I don't know what is the water
and I were just sort of laughing about
about the way you age and how much
difference you work because they pulled
out the first kevin garnett game of
chicago how last night on the SVP show
and levy and I had at quite the salad on
top of her hair which coincidentally
looks a lot like my quarantine here
right now um there was a lot of it but
you know you you I don't know I think I
look a lot different but I do fear that
one day I'm just gonna wake up and you
know right now I'm 54 and hopefully I
can pass for that or a few years younger
but I'm afraid that one morning I'm just
gonna wake up and look in the mirror and
I'm gonna look 83 no you're not no
you're not you're not gonna like Bob
Barker at one day wagon and suddenly
look for eighty years older agrees did
you get carted like come on man take it
as a compliment when when it happened
yeah are you serious you really get
carded in sometimes I think I want to be
and then I realize that the thing that
has made me grasp my age as I used I
won't say I was offended but up until
the last few years you know you'd meet
somebody at college game didn't some kid
would say you know I grew up watching
you and I'd almost be offended by it go
know we know he didn't haven't been
doing that this long and then it's been
it occurs to me wait a minute you're the
same age as my kids and my kids grew
certainly grew up watching be so yeah I
guess you did so on Risa I remember you
at you and your wife were so kind in my
first year there we were talking about
96 so I spent Thanksgiving of 96 with
you in your house you invited me there
cuz you know my parents lived in New
Jersey at the time and I couldn't get
there I think I was doing a sports
center or something like that you
invited me in how old was your son in 96
was he born yet or is he no he's not
been born he was born in summer of 9
so I hear from people yeah I've you know
I grew up watching you too and I'm like
how old are you and they're like I'm 29
I'm 31 and I'm like oh my god they were
like a great light it's a little it's a
little daunting to say the least I know
so a few minutes left with you let's
let's talk about my uh my college coach
Jim Harbaugh went on get up today and I
guess this might also be the sign of the
times that this is quote unquote news
that he's like yeah let's let's play
with no offense I'm ready to play with
no fans I think maybe everybody in every
sports getting ready to play with no
fans as long as it can be healthy we had
brian kelly on the show the other day
from Notre Dame and he was talking about
you know they're getting ready for no
solid bars like they literally two are
down to the granular level of planning
for when the kids if they do come and
that they don't have a protocol the hand
to parents yet because the parents need
to put kids on the plane to put in his
care to actually maybe go back to school
and and play football what do you think
I'm sure you're asked this all the time
what do you think about the prospect of
a college football season in 2020 reason
I'm still optimistic and more optimistic
by the day that it will happen in some
form obviously you know it will be
adjusted and almost certainly adjusted
in terms of the crowd perhaps adjusted
in terms of schedule whether that's
truncated or rearranged or mostly
conference games or whatever that might
be but I I think that there is such
momentum rich and such a need
financially for the schools to play and
honestly I think it's a pretty cynical
view to say it's just financial I think
that that really the the culture needs
it a return and if we can safely do so
and I would hope that goes without
saying but if we can undertaking a
reasonable amount of risk you know if
everything had carries some risk if we
can undertake a reasonable amount of
risk and think that we can do it almost
as or as safely as possible I think it
would be good for everybody
if we play I think the players
considerations and whether they think
that they feel secure
and safe doing it should carry a lot of
weight - we haven't heard enough from
them I think that most people in that
age group and you know having having a
college athlete in the house it's
itching to to get back I think most feel
like he does that they they want to
undertake the risk and hope that it's
not a big one they will be protected as
best they can but I'm optimistic that
that they were playing I think Jim's
right he'll probably be in front of
limited fans or no fans and it will
certainly be a different viewing
experience for people but I think in the
long run that it would be something that
would be healthy if as you said at the
beginning if we can do it reasonably and
and with this much safety is part yeah I
guess so I'd love it to again we have no
earthly idea what's going to happen and
how it can happen but you're hearing
that if kids aren't back on college
campuses from various big five
commissioners of the sport that there's
gonna be no sports and you have to
wonder how our kids gonna be back on
college campuses right now that's yeah
the one thing I plan and read the plan
that Notre Dame has in terms of they've
adjusted their academic schedule and
this is not just for athletes this is
for students as well and I do believe
that because sort of the insular nature
of Notre Dame and everybody living in
you know on campus or out there that if
if there's any place that can do it
effectively I would I would put my money
on Notre Dame to be able to do so and
I'm sure that they still understand that
there's some risk involved sure the
issue there is Reese's I talked about
with Brian Kelly is that their their
their schedule is like a United Nations
of conferences you know so there's I
believe six ACC couple of Big Ten a
couple of pac-12 so they might not even
be able it's not like that one
conference can get together and say we
are playing thus there are 10 to 12
teams within that conference that has an
intact schedule I do believe that Brian
Kelly say something about Western
Michigan if the Inc was
they were gonna show up to play is what
he said you know they've got a game
against Navy and Ireland for crying out
loud in which he he theorized that they
could possibly play that in Maryland but
so even if they say we've got this plan
how do they get a schedule they need
multiple conferences to to agree on this
and that's the thing rich I do think
that there's a lot of momentum for at
least most of the schools in the ACC to
be willing to play now I think all the
commissioners have acknowledged
especially with that conference because
of his geographical footprint that it if
there might be a situation where a
couple of the schools can't play I
certainly hope that all of them are able
to do so safely but that's a possibility
that's why what I mean when I say
schedules could be adjusted but if most
of the ACC is playing the Notre Dame
would have that chunk of schedule and
then there are other games against the
other conferences it could it could make
it challenging for them but you know my
thing was more so that I think the
university because of the way they go
about their business in the way
everybody is right there in a relatively
confined area and from what I read this
is just for the students at large they
already have a plan for if a student
becomes ill and test positive where
would they take them where would they
live how would they treat them they've
got all of those types of things mapped
out I'm sure they don't have everything
covered because there's no way any human
being could but they certainly at least
based on what I read seem to have a
really detailed complete plan to deal
with it on campus to try to you know
ensure everybody's health you know be
tested when they come in and all that
kind of thing so but as it pertains to
football it certainly would be a
challenge if a couple of programs on
their schedule we're not in a position
to be able to travel or play and it
would they would create some create some
challenges but I think that you know I'm
still optimistic that that the majority
of the schools will be able to play and
I hope that I hope that all of them that
that feel comfortable doing so we're
able to do so
how's course so is he good healthy is he
these byes quarantined I mean how's he
doing talk to him talk to him
a few weeks ago he sounded great said
that he was staying away from everybody
and just hitting the lake close to his
house and doing some fishing
so he's yeah he's he's doing well he was
doing well so I imagine
have you heard internally at all about
college game days plans that you're
gonna be most least we've had
discussions for every every possible
contingency plan I'll be involved in
some more those in the coming weeks that
you mentioned the Notre Dame Navy game
that was a you know that we're still no
no announcement has been made about that
right but you know the game in Dublin
was supposed to be a great way to kick
off week 0 College GameDay was going to
Ireland you know we had this spectacular
location for our set and you know a lot
of big plans for that so you know if
that in fact doesn't happen which as I
said you know it hasn't been made
official yet but it seems you know
honesty compels me that seems unlikely
but you know if it doesn't happen
that'll be disappointing but we have to
figure out a way to continue to conduct
the shows safely and still maintain the
character of the show which is to
involve the fans now that might mean
something virtual like we had in the NFL
draft it might mean a limited crowd size
you know nobody knows for sure what that
means yet but we are we're kind of
working through some plans of how would
we execute this how would we you know
would we find a spot on campus as
opposed to a spot that would invite big
crowds all of those things that would
you know be in compliance with whatever
local officials and whatever medical
personnel thought was the safest and
best thing for us to do man things you
take for granted right things you
titrate until there's I mean it's maybe
for just little things like you know
that little adrenaline rush it you get
walking to the set on Saturday morning
and just sort of running down and
slapping hands and shaking hands and
fist bumping with everybody in line and
and being fired up when everybody's in
their shoulder-to-shoulder that you know
that seemed like the Norman and when it
wasn't just a sea of humanity for as far
as you could see I wouldn't say it's not
disappointing which I caught man I wish
the crowd were bigger now you're like
all this all these crowds were
phenomenal and it's something that
hopefully we'll be able to do at some
point in the future if you know once
it's able to be done safely I'm into
that Reese I'm into that all right
before I let you go what is the one
movie that you haven't seen that you'd
be embarrassed to share let's kick kick
us off on this day Reese where again
I've got one more in my in my in my if
you want to say quiver that I've never
seen that is going to deeply upset most
people who take in this show so go for
it reasonable I think a lot of people
are gonna be upset with me because when
I say this because my favorite movie of
all time is o brother where art thou I
love Burn After Reading I love Fargo I
love raising Arizona and for some reason
I've never sat down and from start to
finish to watch The Big Lebowski Wow so
the Coen the Coen brothers I love love
their work I don't I've seen parts of it
but I don't I don't know why I just
haven't seen that okay I need to do so
now here's the gears of the neat thing
is in the same way I've never seen you
know a lot of it Point Break and I know
you guys are telling me hey sit down
I'll be great
I still wonder if after two hours I'll
wonder why I did that
okay The Big Lebowski I'm like jealous
that you that that will be new to you
John Goodman John Turturro obviously you
know the great Lebowski himself and Jeff
Bridges just that's just to name three
all right so put it all together by the
way I do believe there is a through line
between Roadhouse and they'll big Big
Lebowski in the character actor Ben
Gazzara I think was in both of them
Reese so you've got a little bit I've
got a Ben Gazzara blind spot and you've
got another one too I will look for it
I'm going I'm going to watch it as I
said I've seen parts of it I don't know
it's one of those things you can't
explain why okay I just happened all
right race things what are you doing
right now Reese yeah
do you think I should go watch that
important I should go watch it right now
I think that's a pretty good idea your
children are grown and they're out of
the house essentially is it just you and
your wife know my kids are back here
because the court ain't no book back
here okay
well I've got you know like home
schooling going on I've got a locker I
couldn't even imagine it when I'm
fitting point break-in at all with an
eleven nine and six at home you've got
you've got some big lebowski Tom I think
that you can possibly fill in there
brother
and fill this spot and let us know what
you think I will I'll give you a
comprehensive review once I do that
Reese you're good man thanks for
watching yesterday Tech study right away
right back at you that's rece Davis the
best no Big Lebowski that's a pretty big
one
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here